[Music]
so starting with some breaking news this
hour and israel's iron dome defense
system has intercepted 10 rockets
which have been fired from southern
lebanon
so sirens sounded in northern israel and
in the occupied golan heights after
these rockets were fired hezbollah has
claimed responsibility
on wednesday israel conducted airstrikes
against targets in
lebanon in response to rocket fire
xenocode is on our way to the border
area now on the phone
for us what more have you learned so far
xena
well come out like you mentioned
hezbollah claiming responsibility
saying their troops are responsible for
launching these rockets now in their
statement
they mentioned that they targeted an
open
area around israeli military outposts
which is really very telling because
what they're trying to say and this is
what we understand from sources close to
hezbollah
is that this is a message to the
israelis
it is first of all in response to
israeli airstrikes
early on thursday israeli airstrikes
targeted some areas in southern lebanon
in response to
rocket fire from southern lebanon
targeted israel
on wednesday so the message hezbollah is
giving the israelis right now
is that the war this is a warning the
ball
is now in your court uh the rules of
engagement have to change
if you decide to carry out air strikes
which
have not happened since the 2006
war between hezbollah and israel in the
past when there has been cross-border
fire israel responds
with artillery shelling and not air
strikes so hezbollah is saying
that the rules of engagement have now
changed and now the ball is in your
court
either there will be calm after this uh
incident
or an escalation so the situation is
precarious
definitely a marked escalation along the
border
these are two long-time enemies who are
now sending messages to each other but
many in lebanon will also tell you that
this escalation
is undoubtedly linked to what is going
on
in the region the regional escalation if
you like as well
because lebanon is entangled hezbollah
of course being
an ally of of iran but for the time
being it seems
that hezbollah is keen on not opening a
front
and hezbollah telling the israelis this
is in response to israeli um
airstrikes and the ball is now in your
court
zaina just tell me about the areas where
this is happening on the border is it
i mean are there population centers
there a lot of the pictures we're
looking at right now seem to be sort of
a lot of
uh empty land but you can tell us more
about the geography
yes empty land both of them have been
very careful both the israelis and
hezbollah to avoid any casualties
first of all shibash the shiva forms um
these this this area is considered by
lebanon as occupied
uh territory um the israelis see this as
part of the golan heights the united
nations is still not
determined because syria has not given
uh maps to prove that this is lebanon
lebanese territory but the bottom line
is for hezbollah to choose
to target shabbat farms an area that
lebanon considers occupied territory
it too is trying not to escalate
the situation it didn't decide to target
for example
israeli population centers along the
border
and even the israeli airstrike early on
thursday
um did not target um hezbollah positions
they said
near hezbollah position so both sides
really treading carefully because
um any any wrong move here uh could
lead to all-out war and we've we've said
this time and time again over the past
few months
when uh there has been cross-border fire
each side
is not in a position now to deal with an
all-out war especially lebanon for
example
a very a precarious situation the
economy has
all but collapsed if hezbollah does
ignite a war
it already has very few friends in this
country if you like blaming it for
for controlling the decision on whether
to launch war
or or peace in in lebanon so right now
the indication
is that both sides are treading
carefully trying to avoid uh
an all-out escalation but of course the
situation is precarious and it is a
volatile border
thank you more with zainab later as she
gets closer to that border area the
pictures we've been looking at
uh the iron dome israel's iron dome
defense system intercepting 10 rockets
had been fired by hezbollah hezbollah
has taken responsibility for that
from southern lebanon as zena says
a warning shot if you like but also a
possible sign of
uh escalation after what we've been
seeing earlier in the week